hey everyone I can't believe I'm saying
this we are about a month away less than
a month away from the release of the
Last Guardian and Sony invited us to
play the game one more time before we
finally get our hands on for the full
review and I'm joined here by Scott
Butterworth who had a chance to play the
demo and this is your second time
playing the game yeah I actually played
the game at e3 as well where they were
showing off the very opening segment of
the game where you meet trico your kind
of you know beast partner for the first
time and really just getting a grip on
the mechanics so this more recent demo
it set much much later in the game like
the the demo team that was a showing off
the game was very adamant about this is
really late in the game so you would
have learned a lot of stuff by now so
you know don't don't be too hard on on
this you know you were you would have
learned a lot of stuff but what was
actually interesting about that caveat
though is that it actually the section i
played wasn't all that complicated for
being so late in the game it really
wasn't all that mechanically demanding
it's still very very simple and
straightforward the section that i
played was essentially just a giant
traversal puzzle um I had to make my way
across a series of sort of precariously
positioned stone towers each of them
look like they were ready to collapse at
any moment and you kind of had to hop
between them and so primarily the boy
had to ride Trico to have fri coach um
between them because the gaps were
pretty big but at certain points there
will be something blocking your path
basically there with these like
stained-glass mobiles that were very
pretty but for whatever reason trico did
not want to move past them
so at that point the boy had to like
disembark shimmy across some ledges or
make his way through some tight gaps for
like some much more intimate close
quarters platforming and in some way
move or drop those stained-glass pieces
so that Trico would then progress
through the level you could continue on
so it was just a series of those types
of puzzles it was you know figuring out
how to get up to a certain location how
to move a certain object you know find
the lever shimmy across the ledge you
know climb back on top of Trico and ride
to the next section okay um so it was
all pretty straightforward pretty beat
brief very similar to sections of the
game that we've seen previously actually
um which I guess is maybe a little
disappointing given that it is late in
the game that it is so similar to
sections we've already seen from much
earlier in the game it makes me wonder
you know is the game actually going to
be really short is it not going to
evolve much oars are not going to be
much variety over the course of that
experience I mean it's hard to say it's
seeing only such a small portion of it
but again it's interesting that this is
late game and yet still pretty minimal
okay so what did you walk away from
feeling positive about from this demo I
will say that the world universe feels
very lived-in you really get this sense
that you're you're part of something
bigger and it's very understated it's
not--there's no exposition saying this
is what this this city is or this is why
these temples are here is like no no
it's just there and that's really cool
that's really intriguing for me as a
player to just be dropped into this this
world that very clearly has a history to
it or some something about it some
personality or something you can't quite
you just get a sense of just a vague
sense and that's that's really cool to
feel immersed in that and yet not really
have all the answers hand it to you and
just kind of wonder what it all means
and if you'll get more from it and i
will say that at the end of the demo a
second trico a second like beasts
appears very briefly which we always
knew like we've seen in trailers that
there's more than one but it was so
interesting to see that manifesting game
and did like have this other creature in
full armor kind of pop up and startle
you near the end it was it was
interesting that you know I'm very
curious to see where they're going with
sort of the story elements of the game
because so far everything's been just
sort of little tea
is here and there and and I'm excited to
see how that develops so I think one of
the things people are very curious about
at least I am is sort of how the
communication works between the two main
characters and so you mentioned running
into another trico yeah did you notice
that they had a sort of like when they
saw each other it was like a really
happy moment and they were like
communicating in some way no quiet the
opposite that was the interesting thing
so like the second trico wearing armor
basically just like growled very loudly
at my trico causing us actually to
flight plummet down like a great
distance and fall through a stone roof
and back down into a chasm I would
imagine back towards the beginning of
the game
[Music]
so no it's not a friendly happy reunion
which is interesting so I don't really
know how to interpret that okay um but
to build on on your question a little
bit at that was actually the other thing
that's really interesting about the demo
and this was true of what I played III
as well trico doesn't always do what you
wanted to do it's very interesting is
very much like an actual animal in that
regard or like a cat or something it's
not really interested in following your
commands that continues to be true and
it does require a bit of patience on the
players part because it's it's not like
you know oh hit forward you go forward
hit jump you jump like nope you are
making a suggestion and hoping that
trico pays attention and does it but
there's no there seems to be no
guarantee that that's what's gonna
happen so it's it's really interesting
getting a fuel for that it's very
different from anything else I can
really think of so just that aspect of
it it's such a unique thing it's like
hand-holding in an ico right I mean it
was such a simple mechanic but felt very
meaningful in the context for that game
I imagine that will be true of Trico and
the way that he interacts with the boy
as well yeah so okay the game is coming
out soon and they're confident enough to
show it to us at this point we have to
assume that the game is basically
finished so it's fair to ask are you
concerned about anything is there
anything that you saw that just made you
feel like crap hahaha this might be a
problem so as I alluded to earlier the
one big concern for me is that the game
is still so kind of simplistic so late
in the game that there really aren't any
mechanics makes me wonder you know if
there's going to be sort of enough
varieties to sustain my interest through
the course of the entire campaign or or
maybe the campaign will be incredibly or
unexpectedly brief and that's why there
isn't going to be much development
between you know this early section that
I've already played in this later
section that I just played yeah um but
it's also hard to say and I think as
with a lot of for me to gattis games it
will be about the relationship between
the characters and sort of that sense of
immersion and almost the sense of wonder
that comes from playing the game and
it's really hard to get a sense of that
in a you know 20 30 minute demo so I'm
concerned about gameplay variety but my
hope is that I won't
because I will be so immersed in the
story and so enraptured by everything
that's going on that it won't actually
matter hard to say again short demo but
that's that sort of where I'm at
mentally prior to the game's launch
which as you put it out is less than a
month away at this point this are the
how do you feel about the like the style
of animations and controls that have
carried over you know from a waiter's
pass right like by all accounts when I
can tell this looks like another like
loose and fluid game it's not really
like tight responsive controls is that
the case and do you think if so that
that still works in this day and age
this is a very interesting question this
is actually something so I had a chance
to interview you ADA is what in addition
to supplying the demo home we talked
about this a bit and people should
definitely go to the site and find the
interview which will be probably running
alongside this video it is interesting I
it doesn't feel like you're playing a
ps3 game I mean obviously Last Guardian
started as a pious tricked project that
has now become a ps4 project but in
playing it I mean it felt you know like
a reasonably well put together a
platform right I found the controls are
responsive enough certainly there are
some idiosyncrasies that I imagine we'll
take a little getting used to there are
certain sort of humbly things of like
trying to climb around him and like get
to get on his back and the camera will
kind of position itself in a weird way
and so it wasn't always perfect but I
also didn't find it like distractingly
bad or anything like that I mean it's
yeah it's not a similar to the old style
it does it feel yeah I would say so I
mean it's very clearly for me to you and
I mean the art style the animation like
the oversaturated brightness of the
world and yet even the controls a fuel
in line with like shadow of the colossus
or anybody who's a fan of that game i
think well we'll sit down and
immediately feel that same sense from
this game you know since being a very
vague term for a whole bunch of
different things that all contribute to
the overall feel of the experience but
yeah it definitely feels like a you ate
a game did you have any like last
question any really interesting
anecdotes about the development or like
answers to questions or you know like
maybe people have an idea about this
game
no that's not the case like what was the
most surprising thing I think maybe the
most interesting thing he told me is
that he set out to create something that
was timeless like that was the goal
which is a really ambitious and you
could argue almost arrogant for approach
to like just decide consciously upfront
we're gonna make something timeless so
hearing his response for how you make
something timeless sure how you approach
a project with the intent of creating
something to stand the test of time his
response was really interesting and just
hearing him talk I mean he really is
kind of the autor of gaming right I mean
it sounds like such a pretentious title
but i think it's it's well-earned i mean
he's a really interesting and
artistically minded person so hearing
him talk about that was was great and i
encourage people to go go read that
interview all right well we potentially
have a timeless game on our hands and
we'll know in just a few weeks time for
more Last Guardian coverage stay tuned
gamespot com check us out on youtube /
gamespot
you